make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so it's here yes it is it's here so
we're number two man hmm cool things
going on first
I am moving to Columbus today I start
that drive today so for the next four
days I will be on the road number two
myself and Mariah are going to be at
Lexington comic-con March 22nd through
26 I think it is you can look up the
dates but we're gonna be out there
because I'm from Lexington right and
it's gonna be two and a half hours away
from Columbus no reason not to go number
three make sure you guys check out
patreon right you can add free videos
over there right so do not forget you
guys get add free videos you guys get
the mother comic book show depending on
what tier you're in you get a free trade
and then if you're in a higher tier you
get a free trade plus a treat of your
choice and that happens every single
month and then DUP if you join another
higher tier you're guaranteed a Rob core
ring and then if you join the highest
tier you get a Rob core honor guard ring
which is like totally different from all
the other rod four rings so make sure
you guys go check out patreon compromise
explain yes so in the last video
basically Thor became a Herald of
Galactus and this amazing how this comic
opens up right because what you end up
getting here is you kind of get this
really interesting monologue lastly the
question what would you do when the day
comes when you're worse and your future
cease to exist to be right went the
entirety of you of who you are and who
you will ever be becomes moot in the
silent indifferent hold that falls
across your universe now here's a funny
thing about this we've kind of seen this
right the black winter is what what
Donnie Cates has been calling this and
for the most part there's no reference
to anything called the black winter in
Marvel Comics right so Donna Cates
really kind of seems to be flying by the
seat of his pants with this and so far
as he's making it up I wouldn't say
flying by the seat of his pants he's
probably got a plan
you know I doubt I'm believing he
doesn't have all this planned out he's
just writing each comic and just hoping
he gets to a conclusion that he's a
really good writer so he's got this all
planned out that's kind of a misnomer
but it really does look like this black
winter right this black snow that falls
and then appears to have a kind of
antimatter or disintegrating effect as
it literally starts to eat away at
everything now this is when your mind
gets blown because wonder what this
black winter what this being basically
says is that your world will do what
every world does it'll send its best
heroes against us it'll soon as best
heroes against me and what we get is
Superman then we get the flash and then
we get the green lantern all racing
towards whatever this threat is we get
the Justice League right and it's just
like wow what you do this is I saw that
and I was like no way no way man let's
see we know that Marvel and DC are gonna
be crossing over right we know this
crossover is gonna happen and so it kind
of makes sense now if I'm being honest
with you guys this this is kind of mine
it's my kind of my take on this thing so
if you guys remember back during Scott
Snyder's Justice League he was talking
about how Perpetua who really kind of
did everything you know created the
original multiverse in DC Comics and
then that was basically wiped away when
she was put in the source wall and then
we got the current version of this of
the the multiverse from DC's first
comics running up until now including
crisis on Infinite Earths Infinite
Crisis Final Crisis all that kind of
stuff Perpetua was sent to the to create
the multiverse spike the omniversal
judges so here's my question if for pet
events if that's the case what if
Perpetua is on par with like the one
above all right and so the one above all
is quote-unquote the creator of the
multiverse and Marvel Comics and was
sent forth by the omniversal judges
right so essentially Perpetua and the
one above all are more or less
equivalent they're more or less equals
and they're two of a multitude of
different beings that were sent out into
the omniverse to create multiverses
that's my question i need to be a great
way to link Marvel and DC kind of like
the brothers from the 1990s crossover
but nonetheless is a cool idea right
because what you end up getting is
basically this black winter more or less
covering this DC Comics world now we
don't know if it's really like the main
DC universe but it's covering this DC
Comics world and then the other thing to
really kind of solidify this sort of
crossover is you get the hand of
creation rising up in that universe
right those you guys you don't know
don't know the reference to this this is
from crisis on Infinite Earths right
they're like the creation of all things
right the creation of everything this is
what Corona witnessed during the crisis
on Infinite Earths story that led to the
crisis event in the first place right so
it's cool because literally this
universe is completely and totally
snuffed out and that's basically it is
basically wiped away and so kind of
coming to grips being told this story
and in and really sort of experiencing
this to a degree seems to be Thor now
you get you really kind of draw this
because of this kind of vision in his
mind but regardless of the situation
this black winter is powerful enough to
wipe entire concepts out of existence
and so what we're basically doing now is
we're out a planet called Eclipse and
this is the first of five planets now
remember the five planets that Galactus
and Thor are traveling to
our planets that are more powerful than
any other planet in the entirety of the
universe and when I say more powerful I
mean the energies they contain are
enough to satiate Galactus in a way that
no other world can and it's designed to
do this to give him enough energy and
power to basically face off against the
against the black winter now this is one
of the things that gets a little
ambiguous and in a little strange when
it comes to these worlds because the
reality is the role Galactus plays is to
consume worlds so that the celestial
population does not go unchecked right
because the Celestials procreate by
planting their seed more or less inside
of a world and in that celestial that
baby celestial will basically gestate
and then sort of emerge from from the
core of the world destroying it in the
first place if Galactus didn't exist
the celestial population would run
arrived but the Celestials require
life-sustaining planets in order to
create their own celestial life in that
planet right so you guys kind of see how
this sort of yin and yang takes place
Galactus Cates of celestial population
in check and the celestial population
doesn't overrun the universe right so
because of that it's kind of weird
because we would kind of have to assume
that this this planet holds more power
than anything else but we're not really
told explicitly why it is that it's like
that like what is it about this world
that fills it with far more energy than
the others we don't really know we may
get an answer at some point in time but
at the moment we're not really told this
and the other part of this is that Thor
plays the role exactly if we would
expect him to when it comes to a lot of
the heralds that are out there the
Silver Surfer when it came to like
Frankie Rhea when it came to a lot of
those heralds by and large Galactus
would wipe their minds when he made them
Herald and then basically send them
forward right they would go and go and
do his bidding but that was usually more
often than not done when it was e to the
first of the heralds or at least poggle
actors kind of correcting his mistakes
right so screwing up with a fallen one
in the kuraki that mistake with the
Silver Surfer or it's one of these
things were a herald is intended to be a
permanent Herald right they're gonna go
forward and always be The Herald of
Galactus their past doesn't need to
matter that was one of the cases with
the Silver Surfer
but with Thor he's a temporary Herald
even if Donnie caves didn't tell us that
we know that's gonna be true right just
because of the fact that we would like
to believe that his his story on Thor is
going to last more than this particular
arc especially because the hammer of the
owner becomes heavier and heavier as
time goes on so that's a plot thread to
basically solve and to end a figure out
but when Thor shows up here he's still
the king of Asgard and he still sees
himself that way and so showing up on
this world he realizes there's life here
and the response of Thor is the exact
same response that we got from the
Silver Surfer you cannot
consume this world this world sustains
life but remember there's no real other
option here and under any normal
circumstance if Galactus was just
looking to feed because his energy was
running low he would say okay find me a
new world but these worlds have to be
consumed these worlds have to be taken
and so the responsive Galactus is there
is no other option here you will do as I
tell you to and that's when you get one
of the coolest moments because literally
Thor starts bickering with Galactus
starts arguing with him and Galactus
sends him down to the surface right so
in turn Thor takes his hammer and throws
it through Galactus his fingers
literally rips his fingers off it's one
of the most ridiculous things right he's
like you dare strike Galactus like
Thor's like yes I know who I serve right
because quacks like do you have any idea
have you forgotten who it is that you
serve and Thor's responses yes I serve
as guard and then pulls the hammer
through his kneecap right literally
start systematically dismantling
Galactus and it's awesome to see the
problem with this is the world they've
shown up on seems to be an exceedingly
primitive world insofar as they haven't
truly reached a point where by their
society has started compartmentalizing
and breaking a face on the belief of
beauties right at this moment their
society is just trying to understand
their place in the cosmos right so
that's one of things understand when it
comes to societal progression that takes
thousands if not millions of years to
reach that point getting to a point
where they can start looking to the sky
and understanding it and then crafting
stories based on what they see there's a
huge amount of time that takes place
there and this really kind of seems to
be in that that area that point in time
and so seeing Thor they immediately
launch an attack because they don't know
who he is now if it was a race that
believed in deities they would see him
as a deed right they would see him and
Galactus as deities as beings they're
super primitive people and they start
attacking the way a super primitive
group of people would do and so in turn
Galactus just assembles his world
devouring machine while while Thor is
distracted and that starts charging it
up and so in one of the coolest moves
that Thor does he see basically contacts
if who's the new Heimdall more-or-less
you know she essentially took the place
of her brother then in turn he basically
says open the Bifrost bridge and so the
Bifrost bridge grabs all these people
and starts teleporting them away and the
response of Thor is you can do whatever
you want to to these worlds Galactus but
when we get there any life that are on
those worlds will be under my protection
I will take those individuals to a safer
place and then you can consume the world
now it's not the first time that we've
seen this if you guys remember from
Jonathan Hickman's fan
plastic fork there's a point when future
Franklin Richards businesses younger
self and then waste his younger selves
powers up right because they're gonna
need them for the mad Celestials battle
in the future and so as a result of that
with Franklin Richards powers awakening
Galactus becomes aware of this and so
Galactus contacts Reed and says come
with me and so basically they kind of go
on this little journey this little trek
around the universe and Galactus goes to
a world to feed and so on and so forth
in like for the first time you know you
really get this indication where
Galactus feels fear of Franklin Richards
because he says your son's powers are
awake now your son's powers are back we
need to talk about your son Franklin and
it's just like okay so Galactus was kind
of worried about Franklin Richards now
it was pretty awesome it was it was
pretty amazing but during that during
that whole instance when Galactus was
going to start consuming the world then
essentially Reed asked will you give us
time to get people off the planet manga
LA Kiss's responses yes right and this
happened before in other comic book
stories too it's just really the more
recent one that I figured you guys might
find some interest in but nonetheless is
it's kind of funny because when this
primitive race is basically brought to
Asgard they start encountering like
Volstagg they learn learn what it means
to write to draw different things like
that and so really the Asgardians are
fast-tracking their evolution and so in
response to this once all these
individuals are off the planet then
Galactus starts you know breaking down
and consuming the world absorbing his
life energies all the various animals
they all basically die you know but he
starts consuming the world and then
normally he would leave the world as
like a dry husk right oh just gotta be
this rock floating out in space but
ultimately he ends up destroying him and
Thor kind of chastises him for it he's
like you didn't have to wipe out this
entire world and all the worlds around
it right you didn't have to do that but
the response of Galactus is it's just
the way things are but it's just the way
that it goes you know it was necessary
as this is you know and then in turn
initially seems to go to attack Thor and
then suddenly is bombarded by the side
for like a whole bunch of missiles or
something like that you know it is kind
of like okay like there's a third party
being introduced now and when that
happened suddenly you see this hand kind
of reach out summon something and then
you basically end up realizing it was
Stormbreaker
Stormbreaker is being summoned by none
other than beta ray bill
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained
cliffhangers
if you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the rod 4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like make sure you guys check out
patreon and remember we have about a
month before the next comic comes out
and now
catch you all later Bruce
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph then john h aj Matt and
Jeff are John H lean and mean which is
an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin Asia Joey M Steven Z Austin be
Adam K and Genesis 9 16 remember guys
you can send me messages and I'll run
off whatever your message is at the end
of the video so long there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]